[musique]
Je connais des gens qui n'arrivaient pas à gagner leur vie à cause d'un viol
Dans la zone frontalière, de plus en plus de bombardements et oh
Cela signifie qu'il leur est difficile de quitter leurs moyens de subsistance et leurs terres.
Ils ont quitté son travail pour être facile
[musique]
C’est difficile, nous sommes confrontés à des difficultés pour les travailleurs
L'année d'existence de l'aviation est Sam ci-dessus
Nous avons observé l'avion jour et nuit car il ne quittait pas le ciel
Le Liban est si faible que j'en ai peur
Avant le travail, on trouvait tout le temps quelque chose à faire
Je ne travaille pas tout le temps pour Bona
[musique]
je